moving from
three space to two space we're going to
lose all depth information this is no
surprise to us we're accustomed to it if
you take a picture of me
my three-dimensional head becomes
two-dimensional but the immersion from
my three-dimensional head into two-space
the flat screen that i'm projected onto
loses all information of the back of my
head
and
some
part of my head becomes an edge
so a photograph
is
a two-dimensional immersion of a
three-dimensional object well a klein
bottle
is a manifold that
really is four dimensional and it's a
fairly accurate representation of a
klein bottle almost everywhere
almost everywhere
well not really because first of all it
has a thickness glass has a thickness
it's also
not a perfect klein bottle because a
perfect plying bottle not only has zero
thickness but
its
size
is undefined until a
until mr ryman's metric is defined on it
to move this from four dimensions to
three
it has to self-intersect
this
self-intersection
is
a result of it being an immersion
there's several ways to do that
to
cause this
self-intersection to happen one the way
i do it is to
bend the glass around
make a ring weld here make a ring weld
there
make a weld here so that it's possible
to
pour water in or make a connection
through here and get from
the outer universe to the
sort of insight
can you put water in a klein bottle you
betcha in
our physical universe yeah i got that
but there's other ways to do it so i
talked to george chittenden over at
adams and chittenden glass george says
ah let me add it
so he said
another way to do it
to make
this
almost reach there
and this intersection almost reached
there
this is a valid
immersion
of a klein bottle
i can
go here
i can push this up oops and you can kind
of see that
it doesn't touch
this
immersion allows an ant to walk around
here everywhere
but it adds two edges
one two
that don't exist in the original klein
bottle
the original klein bottle has no edges
in one side
this has one side
but two edges what's been lost from the
true klein battle into here is
two edges have been introduced and it's
no longer connected from inside to
outside what advantage does it have over
your
this has the huge advantage
as george chittenden said of being
slightly easier to make
but
then george says well maybe i could try
doing another one where
instead of having
the break here
let's make the break
along here here
we have
the neck going all the way through and a
large hole around here
let's see if i can show that hole okay
hope that shows
there's a hole that george burnt into
the side of the klein bottle and he
brings this tube right through it
that's kind of what you do in the other
one except that hole then shrinks to
touch it doesn't it correct exactly
right brady
in
my normal klein model i'll shrink this
hole until it touches what a glass
blower would call a ring weld however
these are slightly different
for example here this is a genuine edge
if the glass becomes arbitrarily thin
this becomes razor sharp here
it's not an edge rather it's a place
where the manifold has multiple
definitions at one point here on this
klein bottle
every point
is properly defined in the entire
manifold
here that's almost true except around
the circle of singularities
each point
is defined as oh it might be part of
this or it might be part of this
so i can scootle this
on this one i can also school in however
this hole
is
a different approach to having an
immersion
finally george says well you know we
could do it
so that we demonstrate that the
surface of the bottle is continuous
even
along here problem that this has is
there's a hole on the inside
so he put a
window in there so it almost looks like
this
however
there's a glass window
that
prevents
a connection between here and there so
in a sense
this manifold is continuous
across here
and continuous across here
but it still has the self intersection
of a normal klein bottle
all of these are different immersions of
the same thing the point is
you take a picture of my face
or you take a picture from behind me or
from over here from up there you're
going to get a different view
none of them are completely accurate
is this a completely accurate picture of
felix klein no i can't tell what the
back of his head is like i can't i don't
know how many ears he has i know he's
got one ear
i can extrapolate to say he's got a
second ear the three-dimensional human
being
can't be seen in a two-dimensional
photograph
the nature of an immersion of course
with all these different immersions of
the klein bottle
my friend lucas clark came by
and he said cliff
i've got another
approach
lucas
looked at
a coca-cola bottle and he said i'm going
to turn it into a klein bottle
and
is that possible to see that this is the
very end of
the this is where the cap goes
he's drawn
the
neck of the klein bottle
through a hole mind you he has made a
hole like
this guy here
and he's drawn the neck through
and welded the lip of the coke bottle to
the base of the coke bottle what's
astonishing about this
is not just
the mathematical immersion
but
glass people it will recognize
that this is a borosilicate glass
meaning that
it's a very low expansion glass
all the all my klein bottles are
boros
and it allows you to heat one area
without heating the entire thing
borosilicate
is relatively easy to work with it's
called hard glass because it doesn't
expand much with temperature it's less
likely to crack
this is coke bottle glass
it's the cheapest soda lime glass that
the coca-cola company can find lucas
bent all of this
using soda lime glass
which is
really impressive but wait there's even
more impressiveness about it
he was able to do all of this glasswork
and preserve
the paint on it
notice
glassblowers would
can put labels on glass using a
ground-up
ceramic called a ceramic frit
coca-cola doesn't use a frit they just
spray paint it on or screen it on lucas
clark not only was able to drill the
hole
but he was able to preserve the label
and do all of this glass work
while retaining that it's a coca-cola
bottle that's the actual original top
that he's threaded through yes it is but
i suspect that he welded another piece
onto here in other words
i suspect but i don't know he didn't
lucas keep secrets from me um i suspect
that he
put an additional
maybe
oh
30 centimeters of coca-cola bottle glass
to make this work
but
i'm not going to ask you secrets there's
some things
i don't want to know
and held under water long enough
so you're doing like a sort of a 360 are
you to get the bubble up yeah
this hole
has got to be the same
as this hole
oh
my god
[Music]